[Musik]
so herzlich willkommen in meiner torten
welt heute gibt's wir dann in kuchen aus
meiner kategorie jazz classics und zwar
werde ich heute den käsekuchen backen
und gerade bei klassischen rezepten
haben viele das problem dass er einfach
nicht gelingen weil zum beispiel der
käsekuchen oben einreist oder erfüllt
wieder zusammen oder er wird einfach
insgesamt nicht käsig genug und unsere
oma sondern damit sie lachen
wahrscheinlich über uns alle weil gerade
diese klassiker ja eigentlich einfach
gehen das hat man ja schnell an dem
samstag vorbereitet zum sonntag für die
kaffeetafel und hat den dann einfach
über nacht stehen lassen und der kuchen
war immer super aber irgendwie hat sich
das so eingebürgert dass ich entweder
die rezepte verändert haben
oder man irgendwie dachte mist zutaten
austauschen aber eigentlich sind die
tragik sondern rezepte immer die besten
und ich glaube ich habe so jetzt den
perfekten käsekuchen für euch und möchte
jetzt auch gleich mit dem rezept
beginnen und nach dem video also nach
dem rezept möchte ich euch noch kurz ein
bisschen was erzählen und so ein
ausblick geben für die nächsten tage und
wochen
ich sag jetzt einfach mal ich geld
direkt in die küche und meinem mann
verfolgt mich ich mache den käsekuchen
jetzt heute mit einem klassischen
website
aber es gibt auch rezepte da wir damit
hefeteig gemacht das könnt ihr natürlich
auch machen so hat denn immer eine
meiner oma gemacht und ich finde beide
varianten sehr lecker die schnellere
variante ist natürlich die mit dem
mittag da ist auch der boden bisschen
knuspriger und beim hefeteig ist eben
etwas weicher natürlich gibt es auch die
möglichkeit in den käsekuchen ohne boden
zu backen
da will ich dann aber ein bisschen
anderes rezept machen einfach eine
andere käsemasse das kann ich euch auch
mal zeigen da geht es nämlich noch eine
ganz tolle idee diese käsemasse dann in
kleinen muffin förmchen zu backen und
dann hat man immer so ganz kleine
käsekuchen ohne boden die finde ich
total süß weil die einfach so goldig
aussehen ich zeig dir einfach mal die
zutaten für meinen rücktritt
ich benutze eine springform mit dem
durchmesser von 26 cm
ihr braucht 300 gramm mehr ganz normales
weizenmehl 75 gramm zucker ich habe ein
bisschen den zucker reduziert weil
normalerweise sind es 100 gramm 200
gramm butter diesen bisschen weich 1 1
einen teelöffel backpulver hier habe ich
etwas vanilleschote ihr könnt natürlich
auch einfach eine packung vanillezucker
nehmen und hier habe ich eine limette
und wird hier vom die schale benutzen
ihr könnt aber auch die von der zitrone
nehmen oder sie ganz weglassen aber ich
finde millimeter schmeckt einfach im
allerbesten wenn ich so manchmal durchs
internet schaue mir rezepte anschaue und
ideen hole oder anregungen sehe ich oft
kommentare wurden steht ach gott ja ich
hab's nach gemacht aber ich habe den
zucker reduziert das müsst ihr bei mir
eigentlich nicht machen weil ich immer
so wenig zucker wie möglich benutze ich
mag das einfach nicht zum beispiel wenn
ich amerikanische rezepte nach mache
dann muss man da echt die den zucker
fast um die hälfte reduzieren war da
immer so viel zucker drin ist und ich
versuche in meinen rezepten immer so
wenig sogar wie möglich zu benutzen und
habe eigentlich auch nie die rückmeldung
bekommen dass es zu süß war außer
vielleicht bei den sneakers aber ich
meine ein schokoriegel ich eben nun mal
so wie es aber so könnte eigentlich
sicher gehen dass ich immer so wenig wie
möglich benutze ich gehe an die
küchenmaschine und werde jetzt meine
teig herstellen
aber natürlich geht es auch alles mit
der hand ihr könnt ihn einfach verkneten
zuerst kommt ist das medium die schüssel
dann gebe ich das backpulver mit dazu
und dem zucker und schließlich auch die
weiche butter dann auch noch das mark
der vanilleschote und die limette
reibereien und hier könnt ihr vielleicht
auch sehen dass ich einige probleme
hatte mit dieser reihe weil die einfach
nicht funktioniert liebe einfach total
unter ich habe mein bestes gegeben dann
habe ich das ganze verrührt und der
aufmerksame zuschauer liegt vielleicht
merken dass ich das vergessen habe das
volk jetzt aber im nächsten schritt hin
zu unberührten teig zu einem glatten
teig
[Musik]
probst da hatte ich das vergessen aber
das macht ja nix kann man im nachhinein
noch einfügen
falls ihr jetzt merkt dass beim kneten
teig zu weich ist könnt ihr gern noch
etwas mehl hinzufügen
und wenn ihr merkt er es etwas zu
trocken dann könnte einfach noch ein
bisschen butter hinzufügen
heute steht ein bisschen lautet nämlich
noch verkehr in ein küchenstudio aber
das macht nichts
und dann stelle ich jetzt den teig ganz
kurz in den kühlschrank und nehme mir
meiner springform wie gesagt hat den
durchmesser von 26 cm 24 28 geht
natürlich auch und die werde ich jetzt
mit etwas backpapier auslegen
dazu öffnet jetzt einfach die springform
nicht nur ein backpapier drauf und gibt
den sprung vom rand drauf und schließen
so dass überschüssige kann man jetzt
wegschneiden ich reiße es kurz weg das
backpapier hilft einfach später dass man
den kuchen leicht raus bekommen weil es
könnte sein dass er vielleicht unten
klebt und so kann man es einfach mit dem
backpapier zusammen aus der form nehmen
und dann ganz schön in so einem kuchen
retter den kuchen eben aus der form
heben
aber wir hätten jetzt eben noch den rand
ein dem boden haben wir jetzt schon
belegt mit backpapier und jetzt muss
noch der rand eingefettet werden
das mache ich jetzt mit butter und
bestäubt damit etwas neben rand habe ich
jetzt schon eingefettet und gebe es hier
noch etwas mehr ein
dann kriegen wir nämlich den kuchen hier
später richtig gut raus jetzt nehme ich
mir immer ein bisschen was von meinem
teil holz zu einer kleinen wurst und
form ist damit den rand den ziel jetzt
so ungefähr zwei oder drei zentimeter
hoch
[Musik]
und dem rest gebe ich hier einfach in
die mitte und drückt es schön am boden
entlang fest da gibt's ja auch so kleine
teig geräte mit denen man das schöne in
der form ausräumen kann
da hab ich grad ein super neue style
geschenkt bekommen von der lieben
martina die mir das mal mitgebracht hat
bei dem globus event und das habe ich
jetzt leider nicht dabei weil bei uns
daheim alles noch in kartons stück war
die küche noch nicht fertig ist
deswegen muss ich das hier auf die
typische alte landfrauen art machen wach
bin wenn er jetzt wieder fertig machen
wir jetzt hallo wenn du sagst ja immer
eine landfrau ja das bin ich und heute
machen wir uns einfach auf die
landfrauen haben aber ihr selbst mit den
einfachsten werkzeug also mit meinen
händen
bekomme ich das richtig schön glatt und
es geht wie ihr seht auch ganz ohne werk
zurück ich meine klar ist es so dass das
werkzeug uns einfach so das leben
erleichtert das geht viel schneller aber
ihr seht auch das ist wirklich alles
ohne geht und steht jetzt auch den teig
einfach mit den händen kneten können
es geht auch aber wenn ich schon die
maschine da haben damit sie eben auch
und das mit abstand schlechteste
werkzeug hat wirklich meine mutter zu
hause also diese diese treibe vorhin das
war der wahnsinn ich hab das einfach
nicht unter gekriegt deswegen habe ich
jetzt auch noch ein bisschen aroma mit
drin
ich glaube ich schneide mir das später
einfach ein kleiner würfel für die creme
eigentlich kann es kaum einer glauben
dass meine mutter also sallys mutter
schlechtes werkzeug hat das muss ich das
bald ändern und ihr mal so ein ganzes
set bestellen das geht so wirklich nicht
mein tag sieht jetzt übrigens so aus
schön glatt und den werde ich jetzt in
den kühlschrank geben damit er da schön
kalt werden kann und ich ihnen derzeit
die füllung vorbereiten kann und
deswegen zeige ich euch da ist einmal
die zutaten braucht 125 g weiche butter
200 gramm zucker fünf eier hier wieder
die limette die ich freu mich schon
etwas abgegeben habe
500 gramm quark 200 gramm saurer sahne
200 gramm normaler schlagsahne etwas
vanilleschote oder eben vanillezucker
und hier habe ich 40 gramm speisestärke
ihr könnt natürlich auch anstelle der
speisestärke etwas vanille puddingpulver
nehmen als zu einer tüte aber ich finde
dass man sich das sparen kann erstens
mal preislich und zweitens mal auch so
weil in dem vanillepudding golf r ist
eine stärke mit drin etwas aroma als
vanille aroma und es ist kein echtes
vanille aroma sondern und künstlich ist
und eben farbstoff und es kann man sich
sparen indem er einfach nur speisestärke
benutzt viele machen ja den käsekuchen
auch so dass sie diese käsekuchen hilfe
benutzen so macht wenn meine mutter auch
immer aber ich finde auch dass kann man
sich sparen weil ein selbstgemachter
kuchen ist für mich nur dann selbst
gemacht wenn ich es einfach ohne so
diese zusätzlichen mittel und diese
zusätzlichen tüten machen kann
und ihr werdet es bei mir auch echt nie
sehen dass ich irgendwie puddingpulver
daheim habe oder irgendwie sondern drk
krisenhilfe käsekuchen hilfe das durch
einfach man kann sich das sparen man
spart finanziell und ich finde man spart
einfach an zusatz und
konservierungsstoffe weil alles ja aus
diesen natur natürlichen produkten aus
diesen rohstoffen erzeugt wird und ich
werde jetzt meine erfüllung vorbereiten
geht dafür an die küchenmaschine und
zeigt euch wie das funktioniert und
vielleicht nur ein kleiner zusatz ihr
könnt auch ein paar früchte mit den
käsekuchen rhein geben
das macht bestimmt meine freundin immer
so die hat nämlich immer so ein glas
voll mit rosinen und so weiter drin
also wenn ihr möchtet könnt ihr eben
hier auch eingelegte homo rosinen mit
dazu geben
oder er gibt zum beispiel ein paar
mandarinen rein oder kirschen himbeeren
das schmeckt auch alles richtig toll und
macht euren käsekuchen noch saftiger und
einfach fruchtig zuerst wird es die
sahne steif geschlagen und die ständig
sammele kühl und verrühren dann die
butter mit dem zucker richtig schön
cremig danach kommen die eier langsam
hinzu und das ganze wird so eine richtig
cremigen masse verrührt ich habe
zwischendurch vergessen meinen rührbesen
auszutauschen man muss das nämlich mit
einem flach hörer verhör
also habe ich das ganze schnell
ausgetauscht habe den flexi hörer
benutzt
und habe dann den tag und die saure
sahne hinzugefügt hab da noch die
vanilleschote die speisestärke und die
limette hinzugegeben also die schale und
saft und das ganze zu einer cremigen
masse verrührt und wenn das dann alles
schön verrät ich könnte jetzt die sahne
unterheben
[Musik]
und dann nehme ich mir direkt bei der
springform mit dem teig und füllt es da
hinein und das müsste jetzt mal riechen
diese vanille und die limette und ich
finde einfach dass limette viel besser
zum käsekuchen passt als zitrone also
beides noch nicht getestet hat sollte
das auf jeden fall mal ausprobieren und
es ist einfach ein unterschied ob man
jetzt so eine vanillezucker tüte nimmt
oder einfach nur frisch geriebene
vanilleschote das schmeckt einfach viel
besser riecht viel besser und mit der
limette das kommt richtig gut wollte es
einfach so ein bisschen glatt gestrichen
und so wird der käsekuchen jetzt bei 175
grad ober und unterhitze gebacken ich
habe meinen ofen schon vorgeheizt und
werde jetzt mal eine uhr auf 30 minuten
einstellen nach 30 minuten hole ich den
kuchen raus und werde ihn ringsum
einschneiden einfach damit der kuchen
nicht dreist weil es entsteht bei einem
käsekuchen immer so eine
oberflächenspannung und dadurch reis der
kuchen beim aufgehen und dem können wir
entgegenwirken indem wir nach der hälfte
der zeit weil der kuchen wird jetzt eine
stunde insgesamt gebacken und nach der
hälfte der zeit als sie nach 30 minuten
werde ich ihn raus holen und ringsherum
messer einschneiden dann kann da die
spannung entlein entfliehen entfacht und
der kuchen geht dann auf und singt dann
wieder zusammen und man sieht es dann
eigentlich kaum b 209 kuchen in den ofen
und ich habe leider vergessen mit zu
finden und wie ich den kuchen
eingeschnitten habe auf jeden fall müsst
ihr einfach darauf achten dass ihr einen
zentimeter vom rand weg mit einem messer
einfach rundherum ein schneidet das
sieht man sie ganz schön
da hat der kameramann einfach vergessen
mit zu werden man will ich den kuchen
ein schneide ich würde ja gern kündigen
aber wir sind verheiratet als unkündbar
mein kuchen ist jetzt fertig liebst
jetzt und ich muss jetzt vorneweg schon
sagen ich hab den jetzt etwas länger
gebraucht als ich musste jetzt noch mal
eine halbe stunde dranhängen einfach
weil der teig noch zu flüssig war und
ich habe den ofen auch ein bisschen
hochgestellt auf 185 das ist jetzt
einfach so weil ich den backofen hier
nicht kenne und meiner tochter war immer
irgendwie etwas heiser da etwas kälter
ich weiß auch nicht
und jetzt gucken wir einfach mal an voll
in die hose
also zuerst einmal woran erkennt man
dass der teig da ist also der käsekuchen
ihr nehmt einfach wie bei anderen kuchen
auch und stäbchen steckt ihn hinein darf
ruhig noch ein bisschen feucht bleiben
dass ich ein feuchter käsekuchen ist
jetzt tatsächlich so dass er wirklich
hier etwas zu arg aufgegangen ist aber
ich hoffe dass ich das jetzt einfach
noch lebt wenn daten jetzt fühlen da nur
nicht fallenlassen ich brauch noch mal
ein tuch das ist stehen oder oder
aufgeschüttet naja eben da ich nehme ich
jetzt genau darauf gegangen wo ich mir
aufgeschnitten haben
jetzt guckt mal mit der kamera runter
und zwar hätte ich das jetzt nicht außen
rum weggeschnitten werden eventuell
gehen der mitte durchgerissen oder
irgendwo anders ganz herzlich und so
habe ich jetzt eben den vorteil dass es
wirklich so ein gründer kreis ist und
normalerweise dürfte sich jetzt noch ein
bisschen legen und man dürfe diese
stelle nicht so sehr sehen also gab er
ist also schön eingerissen
ich hab es schön wunderschön aufgegangen
wahrscheinlich gerissen ich habe ihn
geschnitten
ok und eigentlich wären es sogar ganz
lieb wenn er nicht mehr zusammen fällt
weil dann bleibt er schön hoch aber es
läuft auch bei mir nicht immer alles zu
100 prozent gut und das seht ihr jetzt
einfach mal eben ist einfach euren
eigenen herd kennen und das ist echt das
ein unterschied wie tag und nacht
manchmal zwischen den backofen und den
härten und daher ist eben also bei dem
kann ich ruhig immer etwas höher
schalten
mal gucken wie der backofen wird der
dann zu mir nach hause kommt ich war
halt jetzt fünf jahre lang sondern ganz
einfach im backofen gewohnt er hatte nur
ober und unterhitze deswegen habe ich
auch nie was bei uns gebacken
dann hatte ich nicht aber ihr fehlt es
geht auch ohne bestehen aus und warte
jetzt einfach bis der kuchen komplett
auskühlen
das ist eigentlich so das schlimmste
genau er erstens die backzeit die ein
und hat stunden und jetzt muster
komplette kuchen erstmal abkühlen
das schön laden im küchenstudio ist wenn
man die küche eingebaut hat wählt man
einfach in eine andere küche und guckt
euch mal bitte die kirche an halo weil
die tonnen vorhaben ob gott wie ein
traum also das ist echt ein traum ich
glaube so eine hole ich mir irgendwann
mal wenn man etwas eigenes haben vorher
noch nie hier drin stand die technisch
so schön aber jetzt versuchen mein
kuchen ist abgekühlt und es sieht
wirklich super aus
ihr könnt es hier sehen also wir können
das jetzt hier sehen der schutz richtig
schön wieder runter gegangen und hier
schon hier wirklich wunderschön und hier
habe ich ihm leider zu dunkel das liegt
einfach wirklich daran dass ich diesen
ofen nicht kenne
und dann waren die 185 doch zu viel und
die andere seite ist natürlich wunderbar
geworden und diese bedenken dass es eben
aufplatzt und so weiter das könnte echt
so toll machen mit diesem aufschneiden
dann geht der teig hoch und nach dem
abkühlen singt da wieder ab und wird
wieder ebenmäßig und dann sieht
eigentlich keiner dass dieser teig
klassen ist und der trick an der ganzen
geschichte ist dass man hier so etwa ein
zentimeter vom rand wegschneiden
also das sieht man jetzt hier ganz gut
und jetzt werde ich einfach mal die
springform lösen das sollte ganz einfach
gehen
und ja es geht einfach ich muss da gar
nicht weiterhelfen
und jetzt werde ich natürlich mal ein
stückchen rausschneiden das dürfte
natürlich erst machen wenn der kuchen
komplett abgekühlt ist also meiner ist
jetzt noch ein bisschen lauwarm
aber wir wollen das jetzt einfach
probieren und hier guck mal wie schön
der aussieht wie ich nun alles richtig
gelungen ja ach ja stimmt ja war vor der
für den misslungenen kuchen als ich kann
jetzt schon sagen bevor ich ihn probiert
habe dass man millimeter eingeben muss
aber durch diese doofe reibe die ich da
hatte das ging einfach nicht und ich
hätte ganz gerne ganze limette in der
füllung gehabt aber das ist natürlich
geschmackssache und vielleicht mehr
zitrone oder gar nichts davon
aber jetzt probiere ich denn einfach
noch zu warm
also nicht wirklich so dass ich schneide
mir gleich noch ein stück runter
dieses wundervolle rezept gibt zum
nachlesen auf torten welt.de
ihr solltet es mit diesem einschneiden
auf jeden fall mal ausprobieren das
glaubt wirklich super und ich finde bei
diesem rezept stimmt einfach so die
konsistenz es stimmt der geschmack als
ist riesig aber nicht so riesig
es schmeckt zwar nicht aber nicht zu
sagen sie also ist es einfach
ausgeglichen und ich finde es perfekt
das ist einfach das perfekte käsekuchen
rezept für mich da kann ich echt super
und man muss gar nicht mehr viel dazu
sagen ich hoffe euch hat das video
gefallen wenn ihr wollt könnt ihr das
gerne mit euren freunden teilen ich
freue mich natürlich über eine bewertung
oder über einen kommentar und dann sehen
wir uns beim nächsten mal wieder ach ja
ich wollte noch als frage und zwar würde
ich gerne demnächst ein frage und
antwort video machen weil ich einfach
sehr viele neue zuschauer habe und mein
allererstes und letztes frage und
antwort video liegt schon so weit her
und vielleicht könnt ihr euch einfach
ein paar fragen überlegen ich werde am
10 stück von youtube nehmen und zehn
stück von facebook und wenn die dann
einfach in meinem nächsten oder
übernächsten video kommentieren
einfach das was euch interessiert jetzt
vielleicht nix fachliches sondern
vielleicht was zu mir oder vielleicht
doch was fachlich ist schießt einfach
los stellt mir die fragen und ich werde
dann schauen was ich davon beantworten
kann alles andere beantworte ich nur
einfach in den kommentaren
dann würde ich noch einen ganz schönen
tag und bis zum nächsten mal
ich komme jetzt noch ein stück
es wird damit wir dich gesagt was
leckeres schwäbische
was schwäbisch essen darf als
kostenloses so viel sein und gut
schmecken
genau das kommt maultasche fasnet
fahrrad war mittwoch
was bei uns schlafen schlafen schlafen
vorbei was bei uns ein blick zur kasse
genau das mag und wer es weiß der das
fahrrad
[Musik]